mucha desolación dolor pero también
resiliencia la que se respira aquí en la
comuna de Santa Juana una de los
epicentros que muestra la cara más
humana de esta tragedia que lleva ya una
semana arrestando el sur centro de chile
y en el que hay más de 300.000 hectáreas
preliminan preliminarmente consumida
según las autoridades lo que equivaldría
a dos años o más de fuegos normales es
una situación muy dramática cuando
llegábamos al poblado atravesábamos
varios focos de incendios están muy
dispersos se veían varios montes en los
que los que estaban siendo quemados son
más de 300 los incendios que combaten
los bomberos en este momento la mitad de
ellos están controlados pero también hay
más de 80 que siguen estando activos y
la jornada de hoy es especialmente clave
por las altas temperaturas Y por esa
tríada que provoca la expansión del
fuego alta temperatura baja humedad y
fuertes vientos Patricia ayuda
internacional ha recibido el país para
controlar las llamas es exitoso ese
esfuerzo
son bastantes la ayuda que ha llegado es
muy pronto desde la vecina Argentina y
también desde España se enviaba el
domingo un avión de la unidad de
emergencia militar especializada en el
combate de los incendios también 150
brigadistas llegaban desde México la
ayuda ha llegado de Estados Unidos
también desde Ecuador y muchos otros
países de la región según la alcaldesa
de Santa Juana donde nos encontramos Ana
albornoz el uso de la tecnología y de
drones ha sido clave porque en las
últimas horas ha permitido avanzar saber
con anterioridad donde se iban a
reactivar los focos y poder planear
mejor la evacuación de las poblaciones
que en la última jornada la jornada de
ayer fue mayor a días anteriores se
viven días claves para el combate este
fuego que puede seguir
Arrasando el sur de chile durante varios
días más